so
in 1995 javascript was created by
brendan ike
in 1997 ecma produced the first uh
standards document under the name
ecmascript this wasn't much like the
javascript that we know of today
it did have prototypical inheritance um
and that's probably about the main cool
thing about it at that point
unfortunately we were already stuck with
a lot of the bad stuff that we know of
today it's just with
automatic semicolon assertion and double
equals
oh well
um in 1998 ecmascript 2 was released
just a minor revision uh in ecmascript
uh three was released in 1999
um
this one was a big release this came
with uh the triple equals operator
exceptions and the error object and a
whole lot of stuff
most notably uh functional or function
expressions so you have closures so
javascript didn't have closures for four
years it's crazy
um in 2000 ecmascript 4 started the
effort for it started unfortunately it
was just too big
in too little time
and it failed it promised a lot of cool
stuff though like type annotations uh
variable destructuring classes and a lot
of cool stuff according to the ecma
archives ecmascript 4 just never
happened
ecmascript 5 was released in 2008.
it came with a lot of cool features such
as a prettier spec page so we're
we have colors now we're not in the 90s
anymore
it did have a bunch of cool stuff like
use strict and
a lot of things like getters and setters
um and json parsing but it's really just
an incremental improvement it was it was
to set the stage for bigger things to
come and that's where we are right now
we almost have the finalized version of
ecmascript 6.
and this brings back a lot of what we
lost in es4
things like generators and classes and
variability structuring a lot of really
cool stuff
the problem is that web developers can't
use these features yet
because we have to wait for all of the
browsers to implement them several
versions back it has to have the
majority of the market share for a
normal web developer to use these maybe
you're uh lucky and that you can only
target the latest version of
chrome and firefox but most web
developers have to wait a long time for
these things to be implemented
so a quick poll how many of you all use
variable destructuring in your dollar
ship today
yeah like
two percent of people
so 14 years later after we wanted this
we still don't have it i mean i
understand why i don't blame anybody
it's a hard process especially
javascript because there's so many
really advanced
implementations and engines
but this is a simple feature that could
let that could make your code base look
so much cleaner it's crazy
so what can we do well we can write es6
good and compile it to es5
projects like tracer enable this and
this is really cool
this is a great idea
tracer implements a host of es6 features
um i think pretty much most of them i
think there are a few things that depend
on the
additions to the virtual machine that we
just can't compile to but tracer does
most most everything else
and this is awesome this has really
helped with early adoption of es6
features
and that's great
but it's an all or nothing proposition
there's something technically wrong with
it but i think a better culture comes
when you enable smaller more independent
modules
so if if tracer is missing a feature
like variability structuring which it's
not
but if it's missing a feature you just
have to wait for that feature to be
implemented there's no there's no it's
it's hard for the
community to
to participate and fill in the gaps
we all know that smaller independent
modules are a better way of doing things
we're javascript folks we live and die
by our modules
so the question is is it possible to
have language features a smaller more
independent modules
uh so as with anything in computer
science uh this was solved in the 60s
and 70s
this is a hard problem so it's probably
not completely solved but i think that
it was pioneered way back when
um i'm james long and i work on firefox
developer tools for mozilla um and i'm
going to show you how how this could
work
so to show you how we can do this we
need to take a quick look at lisp
lisp has deep roots in simplicity it
started as a small but a powerful
language with a simple syntax
in 1963 timothy hart proposed a way to
keep the language small
but users add their own forms and extend
the language you could do this with a
new special form called macro
later called
def macro allowed the community to
evolve lisp just like adding new apis
they could add new semantics
the common lisp object system c-loss
which was the object system
specified with common lisp was inspired
by two other um systems that had already
been widely used common loops and
flavors these were systems way back in
the i think the 70s maybe the 60s
that had been implemented as libraries
so users could just download these
things add them to their project and use
it and they added new special forms to
define objects to define methods on
these objects
these these libraries had already
fleshed out these these ideas for the
these ideas for the op these object
systems
and it it was a highly influential in
the design of c-loss which was the later
the object system which was included in
the specification
which is pretty cool that you can use
them in the real world before they're
actually specified
so here's how you define a method with
flavors
you'll probably recognize a little bit
more in javascript
so obviously this is not valid
javascript method is a special form
it's somewhat similar to function but
it's a little bit more specialized it
takes the type that you're adding the
method to takes the name of the method
and the arguments in the code
so current currently there's no way to
add this special form method you have to
write your own compiler to do it but if
you do that you can't use any other
language extensions that anybody else
writes
and don't don't focus too much on the
actual feature don't cringe at the
actual method this is probably a
terrible way to do methods uh but it's
just an example of a new special form
so sweetgs is a new powerful macro
system from java or for javascript from
mozilla
now these aren't your run-of-the-mill c
macros switches provides a powerful
pattern matching language for matching
on code
and sophisticated mechanisms for
expanding into new code
it'd be trivial to implement that method
um new special form and really easy for
you just to use it
you just add it to your project and it's
available the great thing is they can
add any number of modules
that have macros and use those macros
alongside of the method macro you're not
binding yourself down to one compiler
so if you formalize the way to add new
semantics just like you add new features
it makes it really easy to extend the
language and really easy to make the
community participate in the language
evolution
so i have a new language that i want to
announce called emoji script this is an
example for you guys um
emoji script features emotion as a value
so currently in javascript you can't
actually use emoji which is a real shame
um you have to quote it but then you
deal with strings and it's really just a
second class citizen
but emoji script lets you embed emoji in
into javascript so you can actually
assign it to a variable and you can use
it
so emotional literals are cool
so now with a swift google search for
emoji finding what you want and then
copying and pasting that single emoji
into your code you can do things like
emotional algebra
so just a happy person
plus fire equals a person screaming fear
and a happy person plus a punch in the
face equals a crying person
a happy person plus
a drop of water equals a happy person
with a drinkable water i'm not really
sure what that one is
you can compare emotions so happiness is
better than sadness
um emoji script enforces good practices
it actually disallows the use of the
double equals operator now maybe you
just really needed to use it maybe you
just love it too much and you can use it
in emoji script
so if you want to use it you have to use
the poop operator
the
this has the exact same semantics as
double equals except it's poop
so there's also a better way to a more
tourist way to throw errors instead of
having to type out throw new error
you can just use the angry face
and that throws the error with that
message
there's also features automatic cat
insertion so why would you terminate
your statements with semicolons when you
could terminate your statements with
cats
uh so now now now you get this better
expressive language where you can do
things like if the user is not happy
then
you can yell at them to be happy there's
not really a way to make him happy with
software
um
so if you want to use emoji script you
just npm install it this actually works
you could do this right now
and you use the script emo to compile
your file
so emoji script is actually just a set
of macros um each of those individual
features were implemented is just
separate js files so you can see there's
the algebra there's the poop macro um i
never thought i'd be talking about poop
when my first jsconf talk but
so as a disclosure i did have to patch
suite.js to support emoji which is
unfortunate but let's just for an
example
so you can pick out individual features
that you want to use
this command uses the the
standard suite.js compiler which is sjs
and it uses the dash m argument which
means you you can pass a module to suite
gs to load macros from and it will use
those macros to expand your file
so this just uses the poop feature
now i i know the irony of me telling you
not to use compilers and then telling
you to go download this wedges compiler
technically yes it's a compiler
but it's really an expander a macro
system adds a new phase to the parse
compile and execute pipeline of a
program uh the expand phase and it
happens before anywhere before anything
else it's really just formalizing this
the way that we want to extend the
language and now that since we
formalized it we just have one compiler
and everything else uh just works
together really well and you get a lot
of good things like automatic source
maps so all of the macros automatically
are
automatically generate source maps for
free um suitejs compiler takes care of
that if you're writing a macro you don't
have to worry about it at all if you're
using macros you know that you're going
to get accurate source maps which i
think that's i think that's a pretty
awesome
a pretty awesome thing
so here's a more realistic example i
have a project called es6 macros
it implements individual es6 features as
macros
you can pick up the whole bundle or you
can just choose one or two features that
you want from it
of course you can use any other macros
there's some really cool stuff that some
people are doing like pattern matching
and things like this so here this is an
example of the fat arrow
module if you use the fat error module
you can use es6 headers and it
which are really cool because they keep
the outer this context so what my macro
does is it just expands it into a
function expression
but it calls bind with this on it
so you get that with just a pretty small
macro
there's also a destructuring
module where if you include this you can
use variable restructuring which
i still don't understand like
why people don't use this more or like
at least use tracer to compile this
because it makes your code so much
cleaner
this is the class module so you can
actually use es6 classes
my module supports the constructor and
as well as super as well which is not in
the example but if you call super within
move it'll actually walk up the
prototype chain and call them move
that's your parent
so this expands out to this which is
kind of the familiar class syntax
class
function
that you're used to
so here's
here's an example of interoperable
features
if you just wanted the the poop operator
and the fat arrow operator you could
just npm install both of those projects
but just pass the poop and the fat arrow
module to sjs and it'll expand your file
just with those operators it it
interoperates just fine
so writing macros is far easier than
writing compilers
have fun experiment and play with things
that javascript might want to do in the
future things that we don't even know
about
this is more than just a better way to
adopt es6 features
es7 is coming as well and javascript
will always be evolving we should make
it easy to experiment and to try new
features and they're all small
independent modules that are easy to
write and to use together
uh so
currently this is the abstract process
of adding a feature to javascript uh
there's a proposal to tc39 there's
discussion there's
finalization there's implementation and
there's maturation the maturation phase
is basically it's existed out there long
enough
to where it's taken over enough browser
market share so it's existed in browsers
several versions back
because most web devs as you know have
to support you know
96 of the of the browser market share so
this takes forever even if we can speed
up the discussion and finalization
pieces this creates a gap between the
ecma committee uh named tc39 and the
community actually building stuff
because this takes years maybe even
decades now i i i think we got stuck on
es6 on es6 because this is so large
and i know tc 39 is working on ways to
push through features faster
more frequent smaller specs but the
implementation and the maturation phases
are always going to take a long time
so i think one way to help with this is
to let tc39 give the community features
early on as well as make it easy for the
community to create features
imagine if every tc tc39 proposal came
with a working macro anyone of you
excited about this in the community
could go and just use that right now and
test it and flesh it out and see see how
it actually feels in real world code
yes you can do this with compilers um
but what i'm saying is it's really only
scalable it's only really a good
solution if you if you can do it as
independent modules as every feature
posted to the mailing list has an
attachment that's a macro to make it
work
um and even better if the um
everyone in the community who is excited
about an idea could actually try it out
they could actually write a macro to
extend the language um and see how it
works and so the community has a greater
participation so i think i think it
helps close the gap between the
community and
committees like tc39
of course not everything has to be
standardized in fact i think it's better
if you keep javascript from getting
bloated by standardizing all the things
there are huge advantages to simply
using libraries instead of depending on
platform features
it works
because it works the same everywhere
instantly i mean there might be a
possibility that you're depending on a
runtime
api that's only available in a specific
version but when you when you release a
library anyone uh you don't have to
worry if they're working in firefox or
chrome um or or anything like that it's
just a library that you just download
and use
the main advantage too i think is that
you don't have to worry about backwards
compatibility so any feature that goes
into a browser requires a lot of thought
because they're thinking
this doesn't break any existing feature
right this doesn't break any existing
syntax in addition to that this isn't
going to
tie us down into one thing in the far
future because the browser is always
completely backwards compatible which i
think is awesome but it kind of
constrains the language in some ways um
if a breaking change if you if you if
you released a feature as a macro and
you needed a breaking change you could
just either fork the library or do like
a major version bump and maintain two
different libraries because it's a
library it's not hooked down to the js
engine
so they give a formalized way to treat
new language features as libraries and
allow the community to experiment
and use things that will probably never
be the javascript standard
or will the major script ever be in the
standard
it might be
but in all seriousness changing language
semantics should should not be taken
lightly
don't use macros just for inlining code
don't use macros just to remove curly
braces um honestly if you're thinking of
writing a macro right now you probably
shouldn't
um i mean how how can i say this after
everything i just said i think it's
because we need to be grounded uh don't
don't experiment on your company's code
base don't cut off the community by
using weird features only write a macro
if the feature is unique enough and you
have time to invest in teaching people
why it's useful
uh commonlist in my opinion kind of felt
felt prey to this it's just way too
common to write macros if you're working
on your web app you probably will write
some macros to do something
this just creates too much confusion too
much divisiveness because the semantics
are changing too much in my opinion uh
closure did it right they have just
enough built-in functionality so you
don't always have to be writing macros
and the culture actually discourages
macros in fact which i think is what we
need to do as well
but we can't simply discount macros
completely don't be afraid
closure was able to release the library
called core async which has is somewhat
similar to generators they're different
in many ways but the core functionality
is that they can pause and suspend
execution of a function they were able
to do this as a library because they
implemented a go block which is a news
pressure form and it compiles the code
inside the go block into a state machine
that they can control it's all just a
library when they release it everyone
can download it and just immediately
begin using it they don't have to wait
for a whole standardization process and
10 years from now might be able to use
it
so i think this is especially important
for javascript the language
the language evolution is already
happening i mean look in angular they're
talking about this extension to es6 to
make es6 plus where they have this
dependency injection uh weird stuff and
you know i think this is fine i think
it's good to think of ways that we can
improve our code
but i think they're planning on forking
tracer i could be wrong with that
or they're planning on forking a
compiler and adding some extensions the
more and more you do that the the more
and more you're styling yourself away
from the javascript community um i think
javascript needs release valves because
it's just such a massive language it's
used everywhere
so macros can be useful even if you
don't change semantics
the
emoji script boot feature disables
double equals and this is how that works
i'm not going to go into the details
but i'm able to throw a syntax error
within my macro
so whenever the double equals operator
is invoked my macro is invoked and my
macro throws a syntax error so at expand
time it just throws a syntax here and
says that's not allowed so this is an
interesting way to not only expand the
language but kind of restrict it as well
in fact if you wanted to use macros
but you didn't want anybody on the team
especially that over eager college grad
that you just hired to create macros and
go crazy and change things out from
under you you could just disable macros
entirely across your project just create
a macro called macro and throw the
syntax here and say you're not allowed
so here's another example of macros that
don't introduce new semantics
macros allow certain forms of aspect or
unit programming which means you can
change behavior or add behavior to
certain parts of your code without
actually changing it
i kind of just made that up i don't
really know what aspect-oriented
programming is technically but look at
the wiki page i made a macro that traces
all function calls
it overwrites the function keyword and
injects a console.log at the beginning
um calls the function immediately and
gets the return value and then adds
another console.log of the return when
the return is happening
and i'm able to pick off the name of the
function this is actually just one part
of the macro the the real macro that i
wrote is a little bit more sophisticated
it's able to pick off the name of the
function even if it's like a
an object property you know
so
uh i took this macro and i i ran it
through and i ran and i ran jquery with
it so it expanded jquery with this
and so with this is really interesting i
was able to run this jquery code and say
what is it what does the execution look
like within jquery so i can grab
an
element with the id of app and i can set
the html of it with of it with to the
div with the class box and i can kind of
see the shape of what's going on within
jquery so if i wanted to learn what
jquery was doing maybe i wanted to start
working on jquery
i just immediately see this interesting
functionality
now certain devtools i think are
starting to implement things like
tracers
but you you wrote this for your app for
your code and project and you know what
you're wanting to look for so you could
do all sorts of things with macros
that are specific to your app for
debugging your app and logging your app
and doing all sorts of interesting
things that don't actually change
semantics right they're just adding
interesting login capabilities so
nobody else on the team doesn't even
have to worry about what's going on
um so here's something a little crazier
this does this does add new semantics
can we implement a simplistic stack
allocated type system
um so we can get something basic working
i think
uh first let's allocate one big typed
array our stack and create various typed
views into it
and my stack allocated type system
allows you to write code like this you
can define a record type
so you have point which with fields and
they all have types and these types are
just kind of the machine low level types
like double and float and you went and
int
and short
but now now you can instantiate one of
these records um and it essentially um
allocates it on our stack which we is
that a big type array and this sets the
x and y to 180. this expands all the way
down to this
so i grab i grab the current stack
pointer and that's essentially my stack
allocated object it's just a pointer and
i move the stack pointer and then i set
the pieces in my stack
to 180 and i'm accessing it through the
float
float64 array
and you can see the pointer so the first
one
is is my my psych allocated object
pointer and the the second value y is
that plus eight because it's eight bytes
wide
so we can have typed allocated trucks
and compile down to this uh this lets
you avoid all those pesky allocations if
you're writing like heavy graphics code
um it's a very interesting way to kind
of interleave this this is a i haven't
put a whole lot of time into this if i
knew type theory better i'd probably do
something a little bit different um if
you wanted to like return this you can
do that you but you could i essentially
copied it onto the heap if you wanted to
do that but there's a lot of times when
you're writing graphics coding you just
want a bunch of local vectors to do some
computationally heavy work and always
doing the object literal x and y is just
hitting the garbage collector for no
reason
so who knows maybe one of these features
does turn out to be so useful that it
does become standardized something that
we wouldn't have thought to propose at
first
and now it will be based on real world
usage and most of the problems with
backwards compatibility will already
have been solved it would be neat if
javascript even integrated suite.js
itself natively but if that does happen
that's probably a long ways off but i
think it could be neat to do something
like a browser add-on that that
integrates it automatically and then for
production you just pre-compile your
code
of course some levels really do require
platform level integration uh just
things like weak maps but i think those
are actually relatively rare
so let's let's look at what sweet gs
if you wanted to actually write macros
some of the features that it gives you
to actually do this because i haven't
showed you any of the actual code
so it features a pattern matching
various expansion strategies
and hygiene so these are fully hygienic
macros so if you're familiar with macros
you know that that's pretty much
necessary for a real world macro system
uh so pattern imaging you've you've seen
this to some extent
this is just the basic power matching
you have a list of rules and the
sweetgest system will invoke your macro
so it's
you have a macro named var your macro
will be invoked when it hits the keyword
var in the code and then it will walk
down your rules top to bottom and see
see if it matches a rule and if it
doesn't match rule it'll throw a match
error and when it does the first rule
that matches it will expand into the
code that's within that rule so this is
a basic basic variable destruction array
so you can see that the first rule has a
curly brace and then a
name and then of multiple repeated names
and then equals object so you can bind
current syntactic elements uh to pattern
variables with the dollar sign so that
basically says whatever is here just
bind it to me and then the dot dot means
match repeated elements
it's just a brief overview
so that's that's the rule macro this is
a rule macro you just have a list of
patterns
there's a a let macro which is
essentially the same as the rule macro
except you define it saying let var
equals macro and what this does is
by default recurs macros are recursive
so when a code is expanded it will
re-expand it and that means that you
can't if you want to do something like
override the built-in var keyword you
can do that a let macro does not
recursively expand well i'm sorry it
does it but i let my grow
if you the var that we've referenced
within the macro doesn't reference my
macro it references what what was
defined as before my macro which was the
built-in var so this will not
recursively infinitely loop which it
would do with a normal macro
there's infix macros which let you
specify a pipe or a bar in your pattern
and that means you can look and that
that bar indicates where that macro
matched and that means you can match
before the syntactical element that
you've been invoked on so for the arrow
function syntax the fat arrows
we need this because we need to look
back and grab the arguments and so
that's this is a basic federal uh
this is actually most or all of the fat
arrow
macro you you get this like you get fat
arrows with this macro i think it's
actually missing one rule for one one
style of federos but this is how tiny it
is you don't have to write compilers
uh this is a little bit more complex but
there's um there's a special form called
operator which defines a new macro but
it's but it's uh has a little bit
different semantics so this overrides
the plus operator it takes the
precedence and the associativity so 12
is the precedence level so if you think
of operators they all have a precedence
level like where they where they group
together um so plus i'm giving it 12
which i think is what the what the
default is and then a left associativity
so you can see that it expands into a
function called add so one plus two plus
three plus four expands and do this and
it and it groups one and two first if i
change the associativity to right then
it's going to group three and four first
and then expand out from there
so this is why you need this special
form operator because it has the
precedence on the associativity and
things that you can do with the with the
other macros
and this is the last one this is the
most complex one and one that should
rarely be needed really it's case macros
these macros actually let you run
arbitrary javascript within the the rule
so it takes a pattern
this is a little bit different it takes
uh it takes a syntactic element that it
bound on as the first argument or as the
first
piece in your pattern and then you have
your whole pattern but then you can
actually any javascript within this
expanded code so i i can check if this
condition isn't true then throw a syntax
error
and this lets you do things like break
hygiene which i'm about to talk about
um so so hygiene like i said these are
hygienic macros this is like crucially
important it's a basic uh thing that you
need for any macro system that's going
to be used as modules
so the problem with macros typically is
we've defined this square macro if it
square x expands out to
these two lines of code which have
another var x so if it was just a naive
macro system
i would have two
two
variable declarations with the name x
and they would collide and they
overwrite and it leads to really strange
bugs and it's just you really need
hygiene to actually have a sound
macro system so what switches says is it
actually renames the variables so the
first x is renamed x dollar sign one and
the second one is renamed xlr sign two
so it renames everything to make sure
that it's right
so this is the very last thing i'm going
to talk about
you might be sitting there thinking like
well this is totally all cool i would
use this except for one thing and that
that said it breaks my syntax
highlighter in my editor
so i looked at a lot of syntax
highlighters and they're actually pretty
loose most of them are regular
expression based
you can do a lot of weird operators and
stuff this is intellij i just chose it
because it's just a really random one
that i thought would be a little bit
more intrusive about how it's actually
parsing the code
but it actually worked fine it didn't
really throw any enters errors most
editors are pretty flexible and they're
just looking for the keywords and
they're just looking for basic
delimiters so that it can indent that
could write and it just pretty much
ignores everything else there are a few
exceptions
js2 mode in emacs actually
literally parses the javascript code in
your buffer so that it does break that
but honestly the more i think about it
the more i think that some of those
things aren't worth the return because i
really don't use like it tells me when
i'm missing a semicolon and that's cool
but js hint can tell me that or somewhat
some other thing can tell me that at
some kind of build time that that's
happening
i'm starting to think that some things
like that might actually end up holding
back javascript because a lot of people
don't use es6 because not only is es6
not implemented you could use it with
tracer or something but a lot of these
other tools haven't implemented like
editors um haven't implemented like the
firearm syntax so it the the editor
breaks so i'm actually starting to think
that things like editors the looser the
highlighting is the better um so i'm i
mean maybe i'm a little bit biased
because i do like to use macros but i've
actually seen like vim works great with
the with uh different operators and
stuff like that basically anything on a
new line that is still part of the
previous previous expressions just
indented like two or four spaces and it
just kind of doesn't care what it is
um
so just a quick recap javascript is
under a lot of pressure to evolve and
switches provides powerful macros for
adding these features as libraries and
we can test them out early we can try
them early and see if they work
compilers can't work together uh they're
they're great for some things but for
specifically language extensions um
they're a little bit more they tend to
create silos
and we can help tc39 we can help
liberate javascript
so we don't have to wait 14 years for
variable destructuring
that's it thank you
so
you